hola soy quin de khan academy y estoy
aquí con megan quien es líder de
entrenamiento de profesores de eeuu
hola megan hola kim en este vídeo te
llevaremos a un recorrido por la
experiencia de estudiantes o alumnos de
khan academy bien megan quien se
considera un alumno en khan academy en
khan academy creemos que cualquier
persona es un alumno y desde la
perspectiva de los profesores todos tus
estudiantes lo son como también tú
puedes serlo eso es genial entonces en
dónde deben comenzar los profesores que
quieren entender mejor la experiencia de
estudiante de khan academy
primero ingresa a tu cuenta de khan
academy luego ve al botón de navegación
que se indica con tu nombre en la parte
superior derecha de la pantalla cuando
veas el menú selecciona página de inicio
del estudiante ahora verás la página de
inicio del estudiante en tu pantalla
puedes pensar en ésta como la página
principal del estudiante que es la que
ven los estudiantes después de ingresar
a khan academy una pista rápida si el
estudiante tiene una sesión activa y
hace clic en el logo de khan academy sin
importar en qué página esté siempre los
regresará a su página de inicio del lado
izquierdo se alistan las clases en las
que está el estudiante y en las cuales
el profesor ha asignado alguna tarea o
meta como puedes ver se puede acceder a
las metas de dominio de curso y tareas
recomendadas por el profesor con un solo
clic dentro de la pestaña de tareas los
estudiantes pueden ver fácilmente las
próximas tareas y trabajar directamente
en ellas desde ahí
dentro de la pestaña de dominio de curso
los estudiantes pueden ver las metas de
dominio que se les han asignado y su
avance en ellas si van a la pestaña de
avance los estudiantes pueden ver su
bitácora de actividades este mismo
reporte también está disponible para ti
como profesor cuando haces clic en un
estudiante de una de tus clases
proveemos el reporte para facilitar la
responsabilidad y estimular la
comunicación entre estudiante y profesor
sobre los avances al desplazarse hacia
abajo y hacer clic en profesores los
estudiantes pueden ver a todos sus
profesores actuales y también unirse a
una nueva clase al ingresar un código de
clase algo más en esta página los
estudiantes también pueden encontrar un
resumen de su actividad 300 puntos de
energía y medallas obtenidas
y eso parece ser un lugar realmente útil
para que los estudiantes comprueben su
avance actual en dominio tareas y
aprendizaje en general
puedes mostrarnos que experimentan los
estudiantes cuando seleccionan sus metas
de dominio claro kim
cuando los estudiantes hacen clic en su
meta de dominio se les lleva a la página
del curso donde pueden trabajar en él a
su propio paso lo que ves aquí en la
página del curso son las diferentes
unidades que lo conforman así como el
avance del estudiante hacia el dominio
de cada unidad debajo del nombre de cada
unidad están las lecciones que la
componen hacer clic en una lección o
unidad me lleva a la página de la unidad
a partir de ahí los estudiantes tienen
la opción de lanzarse directamente a
practicar lo que pueden encontrar del
lado derecho o bien primero examinar el
material de aprendizaje que son los
artículos y videos del lado izquierdo
hay un par de tipos de actividades de
práctica en el sistema de dominio de
khan academy ejercicios que son
oportunidades para que los estudiantes
aprendan habilidades individuales por su
cuenta o evaluaciones donde los
estudiantes obtienen un repaso de
habilidades mixtas los diferentes tipos
de evaluaciones se enfocan en cantidades
diferentes de contenido
los cuestionarios son repasos mixtos de
habilidades en una lección las pruebas
de unidad son repasos mixtos de
habilidades dentro de toda una unidad y
los desafíos de curso son un repaso
mixto de habilidades para todo el curso
y cómo evalúa khan academy la
competencia de los estudiantes en las
habilidades que aprenden
a medida que los estudiantes trabajan en
el contenido khan academy evalúa su
nivel de habilidad y les otorga un
nombramiento de intentado familiarizado
competente o dominado estos niveles
aparecen en los reportes de avance de
profesores pero los estudiantes pueden
también entender rápidamente su nivel
observando la torre visual junto a cada
habilidad un bloque para familiarizado 2
para competente y la corona se
desbloquea en dominado cuando los
estudiantes trabajan por su cuenta en
habilidades el máximo nivel que pueden
alcanzar es competente necesitan
responder correctamente todas las
preguntas cuando practican habilidades
por su cuenta para alcanzar ese nivel la
única manera de llegar a dominado es
comprobar que los estudiantes pueden
atacar preguntas relacionadas con esa
habilidad en un contexto de habilidades
mixtas así que deben completar la
evaluación para ese aumento final de
nivel
si un estudiante ha intentado la
habilidad y obtiene 70 a 99% correcto
los nombramos familiarizado si obtiene
menos del 70% es intentado
observé un anuncio de desafíos de
dominio en la página del curso que son
los desafíos de dominio
excelente pregunta aquí los desafíos de
dominio son una manera en que los
estudiantes pueden repasar y practicar
habilidades previamente aprendidas en un
curso se desbloquean por primera vez
cuando el estudiante logra familiarizado
en al menos tres habilidades y después
vuelven a desbloquearse cada 12 horas
también proveen otra manera más allá de
pruebas de unidad y desafíos de curso
para que los estudiantes suban o bajen
de nivel en habilidades en las que ya
están familiarizados
los desafíos de dominio realzan las
oportunidades para que los estudiantes
se ocupen en la repetición personalizada
y espaciada de las habilidades que ya
empezaron a practicar hay
investigaciones que demuestran que
enlazar habilidades a lo largo del
tiempo y transversalmente a las
lecciones es un componente clave para
minimizar la pérdida de aprendizaje de
los estudiantes y para mejorar la
retención de conocimientos mencionaste
que los estudiantes pueden ver las
tareas asignadas por los profesores como
saben los estudiantes cuáles tareas
terminar desde la página de inicio del
estudiante pueden seleccionar la pestaña
tareas en el panel izquierdo bajo cada
clase los estudiantes verán las tareas
activas o actuales ordenadas por las que
vencen más pronto en la parte superior
de cada lista en cada tarea se muestra
su título el nombre de la clase
la fecha de entrega y el estado de la
tarea si la tarea es un vídeo o artículo
mostrará completo o incompleto si la
tarea contiene preguntas aparecerá la
mejor puntuación del estudiante al hacer
clic en el nombre o estado de la tarea o
en el botón de empezar para tareas
nuevas se dirigirá al estudiante
directamente a la tarea
si el estudiante desea volver a visitar
tareas pasadas puede hacer clic en la
pestaña tareas vencidas en la parte
superior de la página
esto es una gran ayuda a megan muchas
gracias
esperamos que este vídeo ofrezca una
mejor comprensión de la experiencia del
estudiante en khan academy